so there's a guy standing in a storm
and this has gone viral image of
kellogg's worker picketing and 3am storm
goes viral well this these are the
things i don't this is like when you
find a kid you know the drone strike
they they show the kid and the drone
strike and they go this is why we have
to fight isis because and you go what
um
i do like the tony the tiger i'm greedy
sign it is fun because you know what you
can do here with the strike and people
lose you can have a lot of fun with the
mascots you can have a lot of fun with
the mascots like there should be a mini
wheat with the the hammer and sickle
you know the communist hammer and sickle
there should be a mini wheat
doing that dress up a mini wheat is
joseph stalin
if they're not dressing up mini wheats
as joseph stalin
the rice crispy
what are they they're elves yeah the
rice crispy elves should be
uh
they should be painted
uh
killing executives
like cutting the throats of executives
the fruit loops toucan toucan sam
toucan sam
should have his arm around mao zedong
this is fun
this is good this gets people thinking
because you start going oh this is
interesting even the mascots are getting
involved a lot of the problem is i don't
care about any of those people right you
know the people with the signs who gives
a [ __ ] i don't know them but if all the
mascots got together the sun tony the
tiger those twinks who make rice crispy
treats uh and the corn flakes uh chicken
if they are a rooster he's a rooster
whatever his gender is none of my
business if they all got together and
explicitly if there was artwork of them
killing executives burning their houses
down
you know that to me would be a little
exciting i'd want to get more on board
yes
you know get a picture of joseph stalin
get a picture of stalling up now let's
imagine
get a get a nice picture okay of of uh
stalin i like this one this one's good
make that mak give the raisin bran sun
put the raisin bran sun
as stalin